the decision to start a family is of
course an intensely personal one but
have you ever considered how having kids
affects your friends your community even
the country or the world this morning we
are looking at the declining birth rate
here in America the CDC says the rate is
at its lowest level in 32 years we're
focused on that for our partnership with
Ted
to highlight individuals and ideas
shaping our world in our series ideas
that matter New York Times contributing
op-ed writer Raja Holly made his case
for having kids in a recent TED talk
that has been viewed more than a million
times we need to invest in babies in
developed countries if we want to help
save our economy and pensions but that's
not the reason you have babies that's
not the main reason babies have always
represented humanity's best boldest most
beautiful infinite possibilities and if
we in developed countries as a whole opt
out and don't invest in present future
generations and what the hell is the
point and watch choices here at the
table okay so not having kids yeah
well tony is a new baby I have a new
baby they were very biased today sir if
I move out of the light you could just
see the bags coming down what I always
say that having kids can ruin your body
more than nightlife ever could okay but
but you're making the case for having
kids yeah I'm gonna make mother's very
happy today yeah let's do it what do you
got so first of all like you said having
babies is a deeply personal choice and
there are many who want to but can't we
have to acknowledge that and we also
also acknowledge the many reasons not to
have kids global warming climate change
carbon footprint over population but in
developed countries some of the world's
largest economies China Japan the United
States Europe people are not having
enough kids the global fertility rate
has been halved in the past 50 years in
China it's a crisis they're literally
begging people to have children for the
country but is it any surprise I mean
when you have kids you lose sleep you
lose money you lose the ability to live
your life as freely as you may want you
Gayle said it's expensive in the United
States like you mentioned we have hit
our historic historic lowest birth rate
last year and when you do the research
why aren't people having kids in the
United States of America the most
powerful richest country in the world
they can't afford it what's the numbers
you have any numbers yeah
the numbers the United States is the
most expensive country in the world to
have a kid if you don't have insurance
if everything goes perfectly it will
cost you thirty two thousand dollars to
have a kid the United States is the only
industrialized country in the world that
does not offer paid parental leave so
congratulations you have a kid and then
your employer says get back to work now
you have child care it costs me $40,000
a year for child care
so imagine young people with student
debt Millennials who actually don't have
as much as the previous generation now
you're saying have kids raise the
birthrate
well who's taking care of me and that's
why I send the TED talk in order to
invest in our future which is literally
babies we have to invest in the present
and help people who choose to have baby
and you say there are other countries
that are doing it better that have their
doubt Sweden France for example look in
Europe the birth rate is declining but
Sweden France ironically offering
pronatal policies subsidized daycare
helping women stay in the workforce
right affordable health care the birth
rate went up so in the United States
maybe we should help people who want to
have kids help young people help women
stay in the workforce crazy idea
affordable childcare but in the middle
of your TED talk thing that stopped
everybody cold yeah is that you get
you're preparing the you're in the
middle of the TED talk on Monday what
happens my wife calls me and says talkes
there's my TED Talks there's that my
wife calls me from DC's crying and she's
a strong woman she says it took my baby
girl new Sabre to the hospital
we found bumps I said what happened I
just left her they found bumps all over
her liver my wife's a doctor she says
most like this is gonna be cancer I said
should I come back because the universe
just sucker-punched yeah exactly
she says stay let's find out and my mom
happened to be visiting from the Bay
Area Thursday was my talk they said just
stay there crush the talk for a little
girl three hours before my talk the
official diagnosis came out stage for
liver cancer three hours before that
yeah so I integrate it in the in the
talk and I did it for my daughter and
her Sabo we named her after warrior
princess and she is just and she said
she came home yesterday she did her
fifth chemo you did this talk last month
I did this all very fresh this is all
very fresh yeah and
you know as a parent you make this you
know as soon as you hear something like
that may no parent ever hear this news
yes but as soon as you hear something
like that you make this negotiation with
God or the universe trade my life but
the world doesn't work that way and so
you have to fight for your kids you have
to fight for your daughter
that kind of heartache yeah I mean
having kids you still recommend it it's
the best thing that's that we've ever
done
and I said then the TED talk my wife and
I talked about it and we said we don't
regret it first stuff your closing line
your closing so much joy your closing
line in TED talk we'll get it a little
bit later on